his thanos about to pull a Michael Myers
and come back for another film after his
death according to a new report from
week out this covered the mad Titan made
famous in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
by Josh Brolin could be making a
triumphant return in the next MCU saga
the outlet cites an anonymous source
that claims Stannis will rear his
massive purple head once again in the
quote upcoming annihilation storyline of
the MCU which hasn't been confirmed mind
you there's also reportedly a
possibility that the intergalactic
despot who died twice an Avengers
endgame wants be a beheading at the
hands of Thor what did you do and later
when Tony Stark used his own take on the
Infinity Gauntlet to snap past a nose
out of existence we'll make a cameo in
the Eternals popping up in sequences
that show him in his younger years this
could kick off Bannos his big return to
the MCU with a brief appearance in the
Chloe's out directed feature due out on
November 6 2020 leading into a more
prominent presence in films that will
tell the annihilation story and
introduce the MCU to the villain named
Annihilus destroy anything
we got this covered expressed confidence
in its source and the information they
have provided as the person or people
claiming that Thanos's return is on the
horizon is the same source that
indicated taskmaster would be the
villain in the forthcoming Black Widow
movie based on the sources track record
one could easily be convinced that
Thanos is coming back to the MCU rumors
about a nihilist potentially joining the
Marvel movie world have swirled for ages
does this mean that Marvel will actually
tell the annihilation comics storyline
in the future and that Thanos will be a
part of it written by Keith Giffen and
editor Andy Schmidt and host of artists
annihilation focuses on many of the
space related characters in the Marvel
Universe as they face off with Annihilus
an alien whose unquenched thirst for
conquest causes him to unleash the
annihilation wave onto the galaxy
Annihilus is responsible for the attacks
in the storyline and Thanos with the
guidance of villains Crete and Mistress
death
initially forms an alliance with him
eventually though Thanos decides to
betray Annihilus when he realizes he's
planning to wipe out all life in the
universe hmm
where have we heard that one before I
know what I must do I will shred this
universe down to its last atom obviously
a lot went on in annihilation and Thanos
played an important part in the action
it makes sense that if Marvel truly is
planning to introduce a nihilus and
adapt the annihilation storyline for the
silver screen then Thanos would return
for those films however this all seems
quite unlikely sure Thanos could return
to the MCU
yes Marvel can bring him back in eternal
flashbacks or storylines set before the
events of Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame and while the
opportunity is certainly there the
foundation for this idea is flimsy at
best it's not a done deal that Thanos
will actually cameo in the Eternals as
we got this covered source simply said
it's a possibility even if he does
appear in the film which is plausible
considering he is an eternal himself
there's no guarantee that he'll show up
in any other Marvel movie thereafter
additionally we know that marvelous plan
for its face for films and it seems that
no movie in that phase apart from the
Eternals will allow for Thanos to return
in any noteworthy capacity if at all
even when phase 5 inevitably rolls
around there might not be room for
movies solely focused on the annihilate
in storyline with the plan sequels to
Black Panther and Captain Marvel
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and
possible x-men and Fantastic Four
projects and don't forget about filleted
that phase will probably launch movies
in 2022 and 2023 to follow up the phase
4 films releasing in 2020 and 2021
meaning phase 6 will likely play out in
2024 and 2025 by that point several
years after his potential cameo in the
Eternals would anyone really care about
seeing panels making a legitimate return
to the MCU maybe but that's a long way
off check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about the MCU are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]